fait un argument le co by dre grèce oui
il régresse c'est un fait oui on en
parle moins parce qu'un actualité sans
doute plus importante qui qui l'a chassé
mais ça c'est le propre de l'actuelle
c'est pas les médias qui font l'épidémie
sans doute qu'effectivement il ya un
phénomène d'amplification c'est vrai qu
effectivement là sans doute que oui il
ya la fin de mon implication mais après
il ya une réalité une réalité qui est
celle des chiffres il avait été créée
celle des contaminations il ya deux
réalités bien après celles
interprétation de la réalité que nos
médias ont sans doute effectivement
exagéré c'est tout fabrice tu penses
qu'il fallait suspendre qu'on peut
suspendre ou aux bateaux supprimer me
demander ça à moi alors que depuis le
début je vous explique qu'il en fallait
avoir des petits j'avais fait une
omelette norvégienne qui avait glissé
c'est comme ça que tu me retrouverais
non mais ce qui m'interpelle si vous
voulez soyons si on retient de réfléchir
10 secondes vous dit docteur dagerman
que effectivement c'est un outil pour
lutter contre l'épidémie pour essayer
d'expliquer ça ouais oui tout à fait
parce que pourquoi
l'épidémie très probablement risquerait
de revenir en automne non en automne
deux feuilles malades elle a réservé les
croisements qui ne va pas sans lui la
donne
aujourd'hui à hong kong et en
nouvelle-zélande et bien malheureusement
l'épidémie repart a su lier ces deux
pays en vaccinant 1re confinement et ya
impasse alors quand il pense à tes
textes
quel est l'intérêt du pass vaccinale
c'est que dix mois d'octobre la
vaccination malheureusement risquerait
d'être d'accablement j'ai compris chez
certaines personnes dont il est un
fidèle et il est pas forcer les gens à
vacciner de fait le toit fermé pas
maximale en train de retomber dans ses
travers à pour objectif de forcer
les personnes à risque que recevoir une
dose éventuel alors de protection est ce
que je veux c'est un outil ça veut pas
dire que ça va être les piétons crime et
wayne rooney est très sympa mais voilà
une question à mes professeurs sur un
point effectivement avant le pass
d'actionnaires sont entrées en vigueur
je crois le 23 janvier quelque chose
comme ça arrive ou est ce cela est ce
que vous pourriez nous donner les
statistiques de non vaccinés s'il vous
plaît en réanimation sur la période du
bâlois au 31 janvier
j'ai toujours été
professionnel ou non surtout pas surtout
pas pour - effectivement factuellement
est ce que vous pourriez parce que c'est
un outil qui servait à forcer les gens à
se faire vacciner
donc j'en déduis légitimement que les
personnes non vaccinées selon les médias
ce qu'on disait tout à l'heure et bien
sont majoritaires aux réalisations oui
c'est bien le cas alors là bravo répond
pendant pendant la cinquième vague et
une forte majorité donc depuis janvier
oui les personnes non vaccinées vous
représentez les trois quarts des
d'accord il y avait bien sûr un quart de
patients vaccinés ont parfaitement à
jour excusez moi